all right starting today with some
genuinely very bad news for some
horrible people
rudy giuliani and sydney powell two of
donald trump's former election fraud
attorneys although to call them election
fraud attorneys
suggests that there might have been
fraud which we now know there wasn't but
both rudy and sydney have been
subpoenaed by the trump riot committee
the house committee investigating the
january 6th trump riots this is very bad
news for them and very bad news for
trump and sydney powell has not been
having an easy go of it newsweek
reporting rudy and sydney subpoenaed by
one six committee will they comply
the house committee investigating the
january 6 riot has subpoenaed rudy
giuliani
jenna ellis
sydney powell and boris epstein
all attorneys in the 2020 re-election
campaign of then president trump
it's unclear whether any of them will
comply
many of trump's former associates like
steve bannon and mark meadows have not
some have invoked the fifth amendment to
avoid testifying the committee wrote in
a tuesday evening tweet the four
individuals advanced unsupported
theories about election fraud pushed
efforts to overturn election results or
were in direct contact with the former
president the hill likewise reporting on
these subpoenas
saying that the subpoena goes after the
core
of trump's legal team after the november
third election a group that prepared
legal arguments following his loss and
pushed his baseless claims of election
fraud alongside campaign efforts on the
focused on the congressional
certification the select committee is
looking into the causes that contributed
to the violence on january 6th including
attempts to promote unsupported claims
of election fraud and pressure campaigns
to overturn the 2020 election results
the subpoena giuliani focuses on his
ability to offer insight into trump's
state of mind in the days around the
riots as well as his work pushing fraud
claims on tv and in courtrooms
the committee wrote you actively
promoted claims of election fraud on
behalf of former president trump and
sought to convince state legislators to
take steps to overturn the election
um anna cabrera from cnn
reports that her that sydney powell's
attorney
says she will appear
before the january 6th committee and
answer questions but that powell also
still believes there indeed was
election fraud so this is potentially a
really really big deal and there's a few
different pieces to this that i think
are important
the first one is
it's very clear
that this if you imagine concentric
circles of sorts with donald trump at
the middle of that circle
the entire probe is getting closer and
closer to donald trump himself now
sidney powell
uh rudy giuliani
talking about you know records from
ivanka trump
and i'm sorry from eric trump and
kimberly guilfoyle and we're wondering
will they next go to ivanka trump and
don jr what's going on there it's very
clear that it's closing in but will
anything come of it the second piece of
this is the increasingly important
timing of the investigation into the
january 6th trump riots and the reason
that that's increasingly a factor
is that we are now only
nine and a half or so months from the
2022 midterms now as i've said before i
don't believe
that any october surprise stemming from
the investigation
will really have an impact on the
midterms i i just i ca it's hard for me
to imagine
what could come out of the report that
we don't
really kind of know already and
importantly that would change the way
republicans would vote in the midterms i
don't think there would be anything but
that doesn't change the fact that if
republicans do take the house in
november and are sworn in in january the
entire investigation is over overnight
the the committee's disbanded if
republicans take control of the house in
november so
it would be important even if it's not
going to change the minds of any
republicans to have a finished report
from the house select committee on the
january 6 trump riots before it's
prematurely ended if republicans indeed
do take control of the house in november
so those are the considerations and the
committee does seem to be moving
relatively quickly
as quickly as they can
and the question of what to do about the
people ignoring the subpoenas
is an important question and it takes
time to resolve that as the legal system
functions and moves forward
much more slowly than we would like but
not a good day for rudy giuliani not a
good day for sydney powell either i want
to very quickly look at this very
strange interview we i didn't see this
until yesterday we covered oh sorry i
hit my microphone there we covered this
trump rally that took place in florence
arizona over the weekend we covered the
rally itself and we talked about it
earlier this week on the show
but there was this interview done by
newsmax of trump
um seemingly at the rally
and um it is of course trump's visibly
sweaty and disheveled his shirt's so but
you know the guy's just a mess
but it is very clear that trump is on a
war path on a war footing we might say
against mitch mcconnell and sort of what
he sees as the establishment republican
party not very favorable to him let's
look at some of these clips this is a
very interesting interview here trump
addressing fouchy and his handling of
the pandemic we heard some lock him up
chance for dr fauci out there what about
holding dr fauci accountable well he is
accountable he's uh somebody that has
done some pretty poor work you know with
me he wanted to keep it open to china
keep it open to europe we would have
lost hundreds of thousands more people
now it's important to remember that even
you know some of these things may be
true by chance because trump sometimes
might like sort of casually tell the
truth by mere probability
but you know the whole thing about
fouchy wanted to keep it open there was
a brief period during which fauci was
saying mr president sir i'm unsure
whether stopping flights is really going
to contain this and and fouchy was sort
of right i mean you know so even every
single one of these statements could
really be looked at in more detail
and they're they're really not truths
but he wasn't a big factor in my
administration but biden has made him a
big factor and
they have done a horrible job on covet
or the china virus as i call it but
they've done a horrible job what would
you be doing differently right now when
it comes to covet it's actually a good
question that's a good question from
newsmax well one thing no mandates the
mandates are killing our economy i'm
convinced that when you have supply
chain problems you can't get paper you
can't get lumber they can't build houses
they have no nails they have nothing
and i think
to start off with the mandates there is
no evidence at all
that vaccine requirements at businesses
are what is causing supply chain issues
there's just no evidence of that
disaster and people just aren't working
you can't get people to work because of
the mandate so that would be the first
thing i do because almost a non-factor
as you as many of you know we have seen
that mandates ultimately lead to you
know like at most half of one or one
percent
um
staff loss
and there are many
places where it's zero because
everybody's obviously vaccinated anyway
you know there's just no evidence for
what trump is saying
um trump also asked about the situation
at the border which is interesting
because quite frankly very little has
changed at the border under joe biden we
got a charged up crowd out there and
they're very excited to see you very
excited to see kerry lake this is going
to be an important state in 2022 what do
you think is the most important election
issue for the voters of 2022 in arizona
i think the borders for arizona
certainly are and that you know the
whole country is a border if you think
about it you know they're pouring
throughout the country but not really
for arizona and texas in particular the
borders are
a terrible terrible problem we have
millions of people coming into our
country now understand that there has
been no major change to the dynamics at
the border in terms of people coming in
other than
there was a period in 2020
uh due to the pandemic
where movement in general was down and
so
you combine the seasonality of border
crossings with the pandemic there was a
lull
and then it resumed and it started
resuming in december of 2020 and january
of 2021 even when donald trump was still
president continued under biden so
there's the seasonality aspect and the
pandemic aspect but there's not been
this
according to the right and people like
trump the day biden took office
everything changed at the border and it
was like wide open come on in and it's
just not true
you know many are coming from prisons of
other countries over 129 countries they
said last week they're people from 129
countries it's not just like mexico and
honduras and you know etc it's they had
129 countries so trump's still very
confused about everything but as well as
uh immigration and then this is where it
gets very interesting trump going right
in on mitch mcconnell this is clearly a
battle that trump is not going to give
up on and this is going to be
interesting to watch throughout 2022.
when it comes to the leadership of the
gop right now what kind of letter grade
would you give them
speaker
leader mccarthy and
mcconnell well i've been working well
with kevin and we've been doing very
well together and we're working on the
election and i'd give him a very high
mark now what that means is mccarthy has
mostly remained loyal to me in my insane
claims that i really won the election
that's what trump means by that
i'm not a fan of mcconnell i haven't
been i helped him get elected without me
he would have lost his race
and then he goes and makes stupid
statements after january 6 which and
what that means is mcconnell has not
remained blindly loyal to me to the same
degree as i would like to see it was not
my situation this was a just a stupid
thing he did but he's a bad leader he
gave them two months a two month stay
that two months of of adjustment gave
them
a power that they should have never had
so i'm not a fan of him and i think he's
hurting the party very badly so that is
absolutely fascinating and it is really
clear guys
that the
trump mcconnell battle is not going to
subside anytime soon
now whether mcconnell cares i don't know
i don't know how much longer mitch
mcconnell wants to be a senator i don't
know how much he cares
but as we get into 2022 with trump
endorsing people
and the republican party of which the
senate is a big piece deciding how they
want to
um direct resources and effort
uh including financial and public
relations uh resources
this mcconnell versus trump thing could
get very very interesting my interest in
it is very it's it's it's
it's self-centered quite frankly it's
selfish i want there to be as much chaos
between the trump and the mcconnell
wings of the republican party as
possible with the hope that it'll mess
them up and with the hope that it will
make it difficult for them
to do well in november that's my
priority let me know your thoughts on
that you can find me on twitter at
dpakman we'll take a break and what a
program we have for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
remember that you can support the david
pakman show by grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's easy it
feels
very good and you can use the coupon
code wow 22
to get a
borderline illegal discount off of your
membership
joinpacman.com is the place to do it
let's hear from you the people that make
this all possible without you i'm a guy
in a room with a mic and it's very very
sad let's first hear via discord
uh from alex from baltimore remember
that it is davidpakman.com discord
that's the place to go alex you're on
what's on your mind my friend
hey dave you can hear me yes i can
cool um
so i have a question about i guess
america in general
so especially if you listen to more
left news and opinion
it's basically the opinion that
amer pretty much america can't do
anything right
everything about america sucks
is that
is there anything that america is
actually still
better or the best in the world at
that's actually positive i don't mean
you know gun deaths and incarceration
numbers or anything like that
well listen i mean here i don't agree
who who has that perspective on the left
first of all well i well i guess no one
says it outright okay
who do you think believes it
um
so i guess instead of
i guess it would be more
i i do i don't want to throw other shows
on play yeah let me put it in let's put
a different i think i have a good way to
couch it which is okay because the left
wants things to be so much better
sometimes it sounds like the left thinks
the us is much worse than the right like
the us is much more down on the us is
that fair is that kind of what you're
saying
yeah kinda and i guess if you were to
consume so much of that news you it
would be easy to fall into that trap
right i was just curious is there
anything
that america is actually just as good if
not better than say western europe who
we're always comparing ourselves to
listen the us is by nature of being so
geographically large and diverse by
nature of having so many people and by
nature of having um uh so many
um different industries that are that
are possible in the country
has so many things that other countries
would dream of when it comes to
the you know so many of the best
universities in the world are in the u.s
so many of the best medical facilities
in the world are in the u.s when you
look at medical advancements so many
come in the united states technological
culture you know all these different
things i think there's no question about
that i think where the left chimes in
and says whoa hold on a second
is
that
someone like me a social democrat
believes
so much of the good that comes from
those things is reserved for a very
small slice of the population
and is uh not helping
such large swaths of the people in the
u.s but yeah without a doubt the the uh
i mean listen i could live somewhere
else but i choose to live in the united
states because there are a lot of great
things about the country and there's a
lot of things that need to be fixed
gotcha no that that's a good insight you
know that i i appreciate that i do have
a uh i like to ask you travel questions
i appreciate that you humor me on them
if that's all right with you sure
um
do you ever take into consideration the
the government in question when you
travel to a place for example i'm
getting into
the history of china
and i would love to go see their history
and culture but the ccp is right
horrible
do you do you ever consider such things
when you travel or should we i do and i
think i i do i consider it and to say
whether we should really depends on the
individual and and listen alex i don't
know what's making so much noise in the
background but it's crazy i don't know
if you're running some kind of a uh you
know hydraulic pump or something
no a guy was uh driving by on it oh okay
so here's the thing i
at the end of the day if given the
opportunity
to go to like russia or china when
things settle down i would i would do it
because i want to learn about it it
doesn't mean i endorse the government
you know i've because my family's from
argentina i've traveled to argentina
during every government almost all of
which i am not a big fan of so yes i
consider it and i would factor it in but
ultimately it's up to every individual
to decide what am i getting out of this
versus am i tacitly supporting the
government by even going and it's a very
personal decision
right then china is a good example
because if you support a business you
are supporting the government because
they're so intertwined yes less so than
in the past but to some degree
good questions alex i appreciate it
great to hear from you there's alex from
baltimore with some very very strong
questions and some really interesting
stuff going on um in the background as
well let's go let's go over to the uk
and talk to george from the uk george
where in the uk are you
george
hello can you hear me yes i can
hi there um yeah i'm sure i'm just
outside of london about an hour away
from london to the west called beautiful
not the most uh glamorous town but uh
still pretty good that's good um i have
a question about um covet restrictions
especially in the post-vaccine world yep
um so countries like the uk and
australia
what we've done is you know once the
majority of the population is vaccinated
especially older people yes we've kind
of had a let it rip approach um and
obviously it's very different in the us
um in the because of the kind of
political situation and the
decentralized system there
but here in the uk yeah a bit of a let
it rip approach um and
i'm not the biggest fan of boris johnson
there's lots of things you know to
criticize him for
but i think this is one thing that he's
got right in the case where you put your
faith in the vaccines
and then you yeah you open up the
economy and you basically let the virus
do its thing and i think
my understanding is on balance when you
balance health economy
etc i think that's the right thing did
you but did you have an opinion on this
approach do you think it's better to be
more cautious um or kind of just let
things happen the answer is different
depending on what is happening at the
time there was a moment where the
vaccines were very good at preventing
people from getting sick at all
but now we have a situation where the
vaccines are better at preventing people
from getting seriously ill and dying on
average remember on average
and the virus is now so transmissible
that there really is no containing it so
i think the right approach changes as
the circumstances on the ground change
now as far as the uk moving in the
direction of removing all coveted
restrictions including masking which
remind me is it in 60 days that that's
happening or when is that happening
so that is now happening uh in about 10
days in about 10 days okay when it comes
to that
when you look at you know you guys are
ahead of the us in terms of the omicron
wave you're already well on the decline
if you believe that at this point it is
becoming endemic that omicron has burned
through the population and at least
until next flu season things are going
to be well controlled
it doesn't seem crazy to me to say
listen the vaccines have been available
for a year we have a less severe but
very contagious variant which is still
more serious than a cold but much less
serious than the previous ones
if we can keep the medical system
from being overwhelmed while removing
restrictions at a certain point i
understand that countries are going to
do it and it doesn't seem crazy now if
in the fall there's a much more deadly
variant and there's a different
situation my opinion might change but
the numbers
point to
me understanding why the uk is doing
what it's doing now
yeah i agree and i think it's it's a
good gamble politically as well because
you have all these
um
you know the opposition last year in the
face of the delta wave we didn't really
do too much and then in omicron we
didn't do
you know we changed hardly anything as
well yes um and you have now you know
the opposition we're calling for
more restrictions further lockdowns and
things like that and now
the conservative government can turn
around and say
you know we didn't lock down we saved
the economy and we kept the yeah we kept
the country open and yes you know
it's it's uh it's a good thing
politically as well as hopefully
health-wise as well as long as it
doesn't backfire yeah hey listen i'm
curious you know how there's all these
uh clever pub names in the uk you know
you've got like the spotted pig and the
herpetic frog and all these different
things
are is there a particularly clever pub
name in your town
not really
swindon is very known for its um uh like
railway history so there's lots of
railway named pubs the steam inn and
things like that nothing too kind of
cheeky uh in swindon it's too boring for
that all right well we'll see if we can
get something opened up there
hopefully yeah very good all right thank
you so much for the call i appreciate it
thanks david all right wow the george
from the uk what a beautiful phone call
why don't we go next to
um let's go to is it nathan from green
acres florida
hello hello david how are you doing
where is green acres
green acres florida is in palm beach
county
between wellington and lake worth oh so
it's sort of like trump country right
i could drive to trump uh to trump's
mar-a-lago yeah yeah yeah okay all right
that's interesting well what's on your
mind
yeah so
hello i've been watching your show for
years it's a privilege to speak with you
the privilege is mine
i am nathan i am in the city of green
acres i'm a candidate for city council
but recently there's been some drama
which i think relates to national
politics in a way okay so we we know
that the right wing
is going hard on
the cancel culture narrative
uh they think we're they're being
censored they think they're being
canceled anybody with like two brain
cells knows that that's nonsense you
know social media is constantly pushing
like shapiro and all that stuff
but recently in a city council meeting
the mayor who happens to be a democrat
was censored by three members
who two republicans and one democrat but
i hear that is like a democratic name
only okay and i just wanted to share
that because it's interesting he wanted
to just
excuse me oh my
[Laughter]
he god to dispel a rumor
and they adjourned a meeting and the
footage is on the mayor's facebook page
recorded by
an amazing member of the community in
the crowd i wonder who that is um
and
yeah uh
you know i mean are you originally from
florida
yeah whole life lived that's interesting
because um i don't want to get off the
substance but th the word that i say
mayor you say mayor almost like a horse
you know a female horse m-a-r-e is that
a local thing there
i
i'm not sure i always say mayor
that's interesting well listen it all
sounds like more of the same you know
they claim the other side is doing that
which they do and it's projection and
we're used to it at this point you know
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah
uh hopefully you know i get in
and i we don't have that censorship and
there's a bit more stability in the
council but until then those three have
the majority because uh the way the
system is there's the mayor the deputy
mayor who's a council member uh a
council member and then the three others
the mayor has no voting power so those
three have a voting bloc and they're
able to essentially censor stop progress
whatever they want to do yes and right
now all three of them are being
challenged uh including by myself um
and it's shaping up to be an interesting
race now i wish the media would pay a
little bit more attention to but
all right well nathan giving us the
inside scoop on the politics of green
acres florida nathan i appreciate
hearing from you and we're gonna do our
best to keep an eye on uh on all of it
quite frankly we we are gonna follow all
of it let's go next to muhammad from i
can't actually see where somewhere that
starts with the letter t where are you
calling from muhammad uh i'm from troy
michigan try michigan
troy michigan oh okay all right muhammad
from troy go ahead
uh all right uh
hello uh
uh basically i wanted to
discuss with you my thoughts on midterms
especially since
this is
probably the hopeful slash wishful
thinking but yeah
i feel like based on things that are
happening in recent days especially with
uh
the far right wing just
refusing to take a vaccine and
basically making up miracle cures and
disproportionately dying yeah i
hate that i have to sort of bring a
political
uh
what's the word i'm looking for
uh
i i don't know but basically i i think
this will hurt them in the midterms let
me see if i can understand what you're
saying mohammed are you saying that at
this point
the deaths are skewing towards
republicans so much that it they might
literally kill enough voters to lose
some races is that the idea
yeah essentially yeah yeah i mean listen
theoretically
yeah but basically they're saying that
like uh oh midterms like 2022 is going
to be a red wave here based on how
things are going right now
they are losing that red wave here
i don't know about that muhammad i'm not
so sure about that and here's the thing
about it
the turnout is typically so low in
midterms
and although there's absolutely a
partisan gap in who's dying from covid
you need that partisan gap to overwhelm
the fact that the party that loses the
white house in one year
tends to vote at a much higher rate in
that first midterm so i you're
completely right in a general sense i
don't know that that's actually the way
it's going to go i think we need to
assume there will be a red wave and make
sure we're fighting against it at every
opportunity i would be really careful
yeah i don't
well the what i was trying to say i
wasn't
i was thinking like yeah they'll there
will probably be like a right away in
the sense of like oh republicans will
like
maybe take back the house and
uh
possibly
take back the senate if things go well
for them but like based on how things
are going right now
because like
people like ev everyone in like media
and otherwise were saying like 2020 was
supposed to be a blue wave here
and it was another disaster
for democrats in 2020 because
uh they lost
about over a dozen seats in the house
right they
uh barely won the senate because of
the big lie and people like lynnwood and
sydney powell
literally saying don't vote
yeah no that's a good point i think the
takeaway muhammad is we've got to not
assume the outcome and we must all go
out and vote in every race that we have
available to us muhammad from troy
michigan
i appreciate the call we are going to go
to a very short break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's hear
from some more people you can get in
touch with me through our discord at
davidpakman.com slash discord let's go
next to aaron from los angeles
california aaron you're on the air
hello david um i've just had um i guess
like some questions regarding um
i uh fcc standards and everything like
do you think that uh media companies do
you think the fcc should bring back the
fairness doctrine that they had back in
the 80s in order to make i guess
representation of diverse ideas on all
uh networks uh more palpable and uh
secondly like
just as someone that has uh a little bit
of experience in like i guess community
radio like i'm very very skeptical of
adding new regulations on like anything
new sec regulations in particular yeah i
think the cat is out of the bag on this
i do not think bringing because the
media landscape has changed so much i've
said before i don't think bringing back
the fairness doctrine is really going to
achieve what maybe we hope it would
achieve
so much now of media consumption is
internet-based in all ways even people
in cars cars now have hot spots and i do
not think that in a way that is subject
to fcc jurisdiction you're really going
to be able to
accomplish
what one imagines you might be able to
accomplish with it so i think we need to
be fighting this in other ways and um we
you know we've talked before about what
those ways are but i would not waste i i
believe it's a waste of energy to focus
on an fcc based fairness doctrine to
sort of like fix the problems in media
right now
i i agree and i also just think that
like a lot of the uh just outright
regulations that uh have that the fcc
has just more harms independent creators
and like independent like outlets and
university outlets as opposed to you
know the major conservative political
talk networks that have been getting
away through loopholes for decades
yes there's no doubt about that and i
think that this is really going to come
from you know and for i hate to say this
because it's like
sometimes it feels like if you just put
in some law you fix everything when the
real solution is more complicated
the media problem is heavily based on
such a total lack of media literacy in
the country where if we had
better
uh education around media literacy
we would not even need to be thinking
about a lot of these other solutions
that are much more
legally based and it's a long-term
solution i know you can't fix that
overnight but i continue to believe
that's where the solution lies
it's just so puzzling to me how that's
just such a major thing how media
literacy is just
not prevalent especially because in
american education systems they
prioritize so much about reading and
writing yes at a young age from
kindergarten but it's not translating
over our english education isn't
teaching us these types of skills at all
and and
there are countries that start teaching
reading and writing later than the us
the everybody still ends up at the same
level but their media literacy ends up
ahead and i believe part of it is
this is just an opinion based on some
things i've read
at ages four five six instead of jumping
in prematurely into reading and writing
there's more about thinking
and i think it is something that just
should be thought about is all i'm
saying
okay
that's fair yeah well thank you david
all right aaron from los angeles thanks
very much i do appreciate that great to
hear from you
let's go next
to um where do we want to go next i mean
there's just there's just so many people
that that want to talk
how about um how about colin from iowa
colin you're next
hello david can you hear me yes i can
wow this is this is really an honor
david sir i've been uh such a fan of the
show the honor is my um
my my main choice for uh
any news that i do
beautiful um
who wow this actually happened i'm sorry
i'm a little star struck you're doing
great you're doing great did you have a
question today
i do have a question okay so
it's a little bit on the lighter side
i'd say i mean obviously i would talk
about covet or whatever but
this is just something that i've heard
recently among like a lot of liberals or
whatever it's about
okay well i'm from iowa obviously and
marijuana is illegal there
so i was like thinking
i think i said something along the lines
of like what if biden were to like the
present button were to like
decriminalize marijuana if it's
decriminalized in a lot of states and
from what i've heard a lot of the
decriminalized states because i also
live in illinois like illinois is my
second home i guess you can say
and like it's it's uh it's legal here
and there really hasn't been a problem
there so
what do you think about like the
decriminalization of marijuana
nationally and if joe biden were to do
that how do you think that would affect
his popularity i think his popularity
would increase significantly if he were
to decriminalize i think there's a lot
of people who would prefer that joe
biden
federally legalize marijuana i think
there are different opinions as to
whether he could do that
but aside from that it's it's just not
going to be the next step i think the
next step the logical next step in the
progression would be
decriminalization i think it would be
incredibly popular overall if he did it
there would be people that are mad for
sure but when you're talking about
decriminalizing you're not saying legal
recreational pot shops on every corner
the way right-wingers love to fearmonger
about so they wouldn't be able to do
that they might say it's the first step
towards that but i think it would be
popular i would love for him to do it
and i i'm 100 in favor of that
yeah i i totally agree david and for for
one thing for living in iowa like i'll
reveal a little bit about myself i live
in the quad cities so i'm on the iowa
side of the quad cities and i don't know
anybody personally that likes smokes but
from what i've heard a lot a lot of like
the people on my campus they will like
drive over just a few miles just to get
to like rock island to marlene and then
they get the pot and then they bring it
back to davenport i think that is just
kind of ridiculous so now i just want to
make sure i understand because some
people may not be familiar with all of
the you're saying they drive over into
illinois to buy the legal pot
yes they quad cities there's an iowa
side in the illinois side got it got it
got it since since the illinois side is
the legal side you would just drive over
and then pick it up right which
yeah that's that's just a quad city
secret for you got it all right well the
secret is now out uh very very much
appreciate the call and yes certainly uh
oh sorry uh a little quick on the
trigger finger there uh very much
appreciate the call i am in favor of
decriminalization and legalization i
think uh i i am for both i am for both
let's go to jason from huntsville
alabama jason you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
hey uh how's it going david going well
all right um
i know we have a queue of caller so i'll
try to keep it short like one or two
questions
um
one of the things i was rattling um kind
of thinking about was
how
um
congress just usually tends to have this
kind of goes back to uh
um neil degrasse tyson how he talked
about when he was a kid he would look up
to um
like leaders and powerful
um i guess inspiring leaders and when he
looks at congress all he sees is uh
businessman businessman politician uh
law businessman businessman like where
this where are the scientists where the
engineers and i thought
uh wouldn't it
be better i'm sorry about the noise
if
there were more uh a greater diversity
of professions especially if there were
more scientists and engineers in office
uh or also architects doctors
um
just civil engineers just uh a great
diversity of uh multiple professions
and perspectives in congress
yes i've spoken about this many times
before absolutely we should be having
people representing us
from a much wider range of industries
and uh professions for sure no doubt
about it's hard to argue against that
and
yeah that's because i remember uh bill
nye you know this science guy would uh
argue i used to believe
it would be a lot better if
only like if there were a lot more
scientists and engineers yeah
were in office but he would come along
and say
uh if there were only scientists and
engineers in office
that wouldn't improve anything because
that's just still one perspective for
sure um
another quick question um
i thought a lot about uh of course
donald trump he's still relevant people
are still talking about him
um it would if it would be more
appropriate that
um if he ever gets held accountable
instead of being
um
jailed or uh
prison which is unlikely wouldn't it be
more appropriate if he
was submitted for psychological
evaluation and admitted
into a mental institution sure i mean
here's the you know it's fine yes it
would make sense to figure out once and
for all what is going on with his with
his mental state but um you know it's
very difficult uh particularly for for
people in his position to forcibly
submit to that so i don't know that it's
worth spending too too much time
thinking and talking about it because
it's it's not going to happen you know
that's unfortunate i mean
wouldn't there be a chance that it could
be court ordered
yes there's obviously a chance but i
can't imagine any path towards that
being what happens
yeah yeah well
it's it's a it's a thought i had all
right um i'll
uh how do i answer i'll hand over my
call to the next uh all right thank you
so much for the call i very much
appreciate it and a lot of different
things on people's minds today which is
uh which is great let's go next to
vitali from israel vitaly you were on
the air
hello i wasn't expecting to be uh
selected wow well here we are thanks
anyways yeah
uh i have a more geopolitical question
but also it pertains to perhaps united
states
now with the
the tensions in ukraine
uh
we are
possibly are going to into a
confrontation between nato united states
ukraine and
russia
in your mind
well what do you think like the
consensus in the united states would be
if uh like a public opinion if it would
be
escalating to a war
you're saying like a boots on the ground
type war
any kind of armed conflict yeah um
vitali if you can please turn off
notifications and discord because we can
hear every time that it blinks and it's
very very distracting to to the audience
my belief is
that by a small margin
the you the american people would be in
favor of the us and nato coming to the
defense of ukraine against hostilities
from russia by a small
margin that's my prediction about what
would happen
okay
thank you
all right vitali from israel there we go
yeah always remember
to turn off
discord notifications very very
important let's go next to logan from
kenosha wisconsin logan you're on the
air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
all right
sorry i'm in the car i just got out of
class you're doing great
so i was just calling to ask a question
about 2024 sure um
do you think it might be better if it
was trump running
considering the
idea of turnout to vote against trump
like in 2020 it was more of a
vote against trump than for biden you're
saying would it be better for democrats
if trump was the nominee right for
democrats like
personally i think it would be worse for
democrats if it was like desantis or
someone like that so here's my thoughts
this is a really good question
if it's biden versus trump
i think trump wins
if it's kamala versus trump
i think trump wins i think the one way
that it's better for democrats if it's
trump
is if there's an actual
sort of more inspiring
and dynamic democratic nominee i don't
know who that would be i don't even know
if the person exists but my point here
is
i think if it's seen as a rematch of
2020
i think trump wins if it's
tired old crazy trump again
versus
someone else that's interesting i think
in that case it's better for democrats
but it's very very risky it's a risky
proposition
right all right well
thanks for taking my call all right
logan from kenosha great to hear from
you
that's gonna do it for our calls today
we will take calls again next week and i
look forward to hearing from you then
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right it's friday let's get into
this week's mailbag remember you can
email info
davidpakman.com with your thoughts your
questions your
anything really just know try to reduce
the abuse in the email uh and don't send
10 10 emails a day you'll get yourself
flagged directly into the trash and
we've sadly there's like 50 people now
getting auto filtered directly into the
trash okay let's start today's first
email is actually not an email it's from
twitter where a user named akbar said
david who does your vetting for your
calls it seems like a large portion is
just trolling you and getting you to
answer questions that are asked in bad
faith pretending to be progressive you
know there are a lot of really fair
critiques of our phone callers
um including that they take five minutes
to get to the question that they call
from really loud places that they don't
really have anything to ask but just
kind of want to rant for a while
there's a lot of really good critiques
i don't think this critique is accurate
that people are trolling me and asking
bad faith questions i i have never
gotten that impression
um and that they're pretending to be
progressive
if anybody can even point to one
specific such call i
if this is happening it's going
completely over my head
and i should be aware of it so please
let me know if there are specific calls
that that meet that definition because i
haven't seen them here's another message
via facebook
you are a habitual liar
now you know
you can say hey david sometimes you get
things wrong
you can say david sometimes
when it's statistics or math
or calculus related elements on the show
you get them wrong or sometimes you get
a fact wrong
but
one of the things i don't do here
is lie to you
or tell you that i believe things that i
don't really believe everything i say on
the program i really believe and i
believe to be true at the time and
sometimes i get things wrong
and when i am aware of it i will
apologize i throw myself at the mercy of
the audience and i issue a correction i
will i will do that a few emails from
now because i was corrected about
something
but
this is not a program where i lie to the
audience or pretend to have beliefs that
i don't either because i think it will
be more interesting or generate more
clicks or views or whatever the case may
be i don't do that there are shows that
do it and i won't name them partially
because i don't watch them
uh but but there are shows i'm sure that
do that but this is not one of them all
right okay joe wrote in joe says hey
david i was scrolling through facebook
when i noticed one of my anti-vaxx
facebook friends who's a nurse
share the below post from halifax health
in florida i can't wrap my head around
why a hospital would share this how do
we fight this nonsense this is food to
anti-vax republicans can you look into
it so what joe is referring to is that
halifax health shared something showing
that a lot of the people
in the hospital
um were vaccinated with covid that there
were a bunch of vaccinated people in the
hospital and as i've said before one of
the things we we must understand
is that as more and more people are
vaccinated
the odds by sheer base rates that more
of the hospitalized are vaccinated goes
up what we have to understand
is your relative risk as i said before
the thought experiment is in a country
where you have 100 vaccination
anyone who's hospitalized will be
vaccinated does that mean the vaccines
don't reduce the risk of hospitalization
of course not and as we've seen many
times before you know it i'm i'm making
up numbers here
imagine you have 70 vaccination
and 40 of the hospitalized are
vaccinated well that's a much larger
share of the population
and they are relatively a much smaller
portion of the hospitalized and as we've
seen before the risk reduction for
hospitalization or death from cobit is
significant i don't even remember the
latest numbers at this point because we
continue to get
more and more uh precise numbers but you
have to understand the relative risk and
joe is not wrong
it is food or fodder for anti-vaxx
republicans
because they don't understand the
meaning of the numbers if they
understood math
and base rates then it would not be
anti-vax fodder unfortunately they don't
and therefore it is
okay steve wrote to me here's an
interesting perspective from steve or
stephen
trump's vaccine advocacy is an indicator
he doesn't intend to run in 2024. steve
writes david knowing that everything
trump does is to benefit himself why is
he now promoting the vaccine knowing it
will cost him potential voters perhaps
he's more concerned about his legacy
might this be an indicator that he does
not intend to run in 2024
at this point
i have no idea this is one argument that
can be made trump is now going fully for
vaccines because he doesn't care about
the repercussions the problem is he's
not really going fully he's still
talking about you should have your
freedoms and i'm not sure about
vaccinating kids and all these different
things so i reject that he's really
going that much pro-vaccine but the
counterpoint that some people have wrote
to me have written to me and said some
people who wrote to me said
um is that what trump is doing is
getting ahead of the fact that it it
does seem plausible that in the next
year covid will be dramatically reduced
it'll go into an endemic phase and he
wants to make sure that as that happens
people think of him and the vaccines so
so
you can pick any interpretation you want
i don't know that we're really going to
know what trump's thinking is at this
point in time uh eric wrote
um oh actually eric's making this exact
point by the way this is not the crazy
anti-vaxx eric and mass this is a
different eric and mass he says hey
david do you think trump's recent
endorsement of the vaccine is being
caused by some health officials
forecasting that the coveted pandemic is
hopefully winding down maybe he's
realizing there will be something to
take credit for soon so rather than
belittling it he's better off taking
credit for it thanks
this is exactly what i was just
suggesting that some people were writing
to me about must have been in my head
because
we had this email here uh that's another
interpretation of trump now saying the
vaccines are good
the vaccines are safe and i made them
um this is just as plausible an
explanation
okay mr h wrote to me
about dr anthony fauci
and says greetings
is it possible that dr fauci may need to
seek political asylum
if the republicans gain full control of
the government regards
i
am not willing to accept
that dr fauci would need to leave the
country for safety
if republicans take over in november now
a lot of really bad things are likely to
happen if republicans take over in
november there's no question about that
but particularly because he has
armed security which is insane that dr
fauci needs it but he does
i believe that dr fauci will be able to
safely stay in the united states
even if republicans gain full control of
the government in 2024 or control of the
house and or senate
in 2022. if you have a different
perspective on dr fauci's safety
by all means let me know
olav wrote in about a mathematical error
which i always want to correct
he says david sir in your january 12th
show you claimed one percent and point
five percent were imaginary numbers when
talking about omicron giving fewer
hospitalizations
in mathematics imaginary numbers are
well defined it's real numbers
multiplied by an imaginary unit i
i is defined as if you square it it
equals minus one i would rather use made
up numbers instead of imaginary this is
a completely fair critique um i said the
other day these are imaginary numbers
and it really was not precise what i
meant was i'm making these numbers up
uh imaginary numbers have a precisely
defined
meaning in math
and i apologize
if i confused anybody oh with that
ruth wrote in and ruth says the future
of the united states scares me
ruth says hi david i've been listening
to your show for about a year i really
appreciate your reporting on current
events after listening to yourself and
others i'm very concerned about the
future of the us me too
lately i have been considering moving
out of the u.s i was wondering if you've
ever thought about this yourself or if
you think the u.s will turn around yeah
i mean listen um i am i i always
have you know we we learn more and more
about kind of people's um
there's this return to the mean thing
where we learn that people seem to have
different levels of kind of natural
optimism satisfaction and happiness and
individual events will push and pull us
one way or the other but that most
people unless they work really hard kind
have kind of a natural mean or status
quo and my status quo is kind of like
cautious optimism but let's make sure we
have a backup plan in place
so as many of you know i was born in
argentina i could move back to argentina
anytime that's one backup now for the
last many decades
it's not been an appealing thing because
things have been worse in argentina than
in the u.s in many many different ways
so that's one backup
number two is
uh i could move to israel and obtain
citizenship there so that's a backup and
the third backup that i'm waiting on uh
or working on right now is there i have
many of you might know i have family
roots in poland
uh my family from poland on my maternal
grandfather's side
fled poland because of the holocaust
fled to argentina
there is a provision
where if you can prove your lineage and
that your family left under those
circumstances you can get a polish
passport which would give me eu
access full eu access i am working on
that it's really difficult because by
its nature the records
that prove that lineage from poland
are
potentially non-existent because they
were burned up in the holocaust the part
of poland that my family is from
is now part of belarus as many of you
know the political situation in belarus
is complex there are not exactly good
working relationships between belarus
and poland so if anybody here is in
belarus and might be able to help me get
the documents i need get in touch but
that's my third backup that i'm working
on and i have not
seriously considered permanently leaving
the u.s but certainly i am worried
enough about the future of the u.s
that i want to have a plan in place so
that's a long answer ruth but i hope
i've answered it
to your satisfaction
email info davidpakman.com if you have
anything that you want to see in the
mailbag we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
use the coupon code wow22 to get a
discount and we'll see you either on the
bonus show today
or back on the monday program
you